hey look who it is mike florio pro
football talk pm bftpm
coming up right here on peacock after
brother from another hey man it's good
to be you know in the lineup you know
yesterday
we feel supported
it's great to be with you guys you guys
have an awesome show i've gotten to hear
the end of it every day this week and
i'm going to catch up because all of our
shows are available on demand on peacock
we are all
loyal to the peacock brand but it's a
great streaming service and anybody
who's watching right now probably agrees
with us so they wouldn't be watching
exactly well done well done we
appreciate it man well it's your first
visit so we feel like our first week is
complete we got the man mike florian
himself on the show so we're good now
we're official we're officially on the
team um speaking on the team
certain wide receiver that you don't
want to
see on his team or at least you think
it'd be smart prudent of the cleveland
browns to trade odell beckham you've
written about it you've talked about it
this week after seeing him win last
night mostly on the run game but do you
still feel that way do they need to
shake things up and trade o'down
yeah this would be what the great
michael scott calls a win-win-win it
would be good for the browns it would be
good for odell beckham jr and it would
be good for his ultimate destination
which i think would be the patriots a
place where beckham clearly would love
to go and
they would i think get the most out of
him in that offense with cam newton they
need some help on the outside but as to
the browns you know when you have so
much money invested in all these
different positions and you feel
compelled to use the passing game even
though you have the best one-two punch
currently in the nfl and maybe the best
one-two punch we've seen in years at
running back with nick chubb and kareem
hunt i think you just need to ride
through that strength like they did last
night you don't really need odell
beckham jr the problem is when you win
everything's fine when you don't win
odell believes if he got the ball more
you would have won and that creates a
lot of unnecessary friction and tension
and i don't think he and baker mayfield
ever clicked and i just think that it's
not a fit and it would be a better fit
in new england so you could get
something for him i mean if muhammad's
new was a guy that the patriots gave a
second round pick up for last year what
would they give up for odell beckham jr
this year and i just think it would make
a ton of sense and i think the browns
would be far better off short term and
long term making that move
all right mike you mentioned one of the
teams i wanted to want to ask you about
sunday night football you got
seahawks and patriots and i'm just more
uh interested in the quarterbacks and
how you see them both
in different stages cam newton in his
first year with the patriots and russell
wilson a lot of people including bill
belichick starting to give him some love
saying he's underrated
how do you see both of these
quarterbacks going into sunday's game
well russell wilson has been underrated
for so long i forget when it started
this is a guy who's in year nine
he has one super bowl early in his
career and i think he wants to show that
he's every bit as good as the best
quarterbacks in the game and i think he
is when you watch what he does he's
every bit as effective as patrick
mahomes it's just not as flashy it
doesn't get you on the edge of your seat
you know patrick mahomes is running
around with his hair on fire and it's
exciting the build-up to what he
ultimately does wilson just does it and
it's like a cobra strike and you don't
realize what he did until it's over and
even then you don't appreciate what he's
done and i think that well i know that
he wanted that offense to open things up
earlier in the game give him a chance to
show what he can do and look what
happened they rolled up 38 points last
week he was 31 for 35 so i'm fascinated
to see how much that carries over into
this game and as to cam newton i want to
see how much he runs you know i think
bill belichick has tried intentionally
to downplay the number of runs that cam
newton had last week he suggested it was
all out of option looks it wasn't there
were seven designed runs six that came
out of the read option type of a play i
think we're going to see a lot of cam
newton running on sunday night against
the seahawks
is uh is chris godwin playing or is he
is doubtful out what's his what's his
status for for 10.
doubtful he took a big hit late in the
game on sunday against the saints and
doubtful concussion protocol two days
before the game you know i have a
feeling he's gonna miss the game but who
knows yeah there used to be when a guy
was in a concussion protocol
the default was he'd miss a game and
then at some point over the past five
years it became flipped and it seems
like a lot of guys they get a concussion
and they're back in a week so i'm not
going to rule out anything with chris
godwin
what reason i bring him up though was uh
was brady obviously big topic struggled
in the opener you we everybody talked
about aryans talking about him publicly
now potentially going into this next
game without chris godwin what do you
expect
game two week two from tom brady
well you look at it this way the
buccaneers drew the hardest game on
their schedule at new orleans right out
of the gates
and then you could argue they drew the
easiest game on their schedule at home
against a rebuilding panthers team week
two so this is the week they have to
show up and you know brady for the most
part was effective there were 67 yards
of passing that that got racked up as
past interference penalties where mike
evans drew a flag or the numbers would
have been better i want to see more
growth from rob gronkowski i tell you
what he caught a pass early in the game
it looked like he was running in mud and
bruce arians has been hyping up gronk he
is not the guy that he was five years
ago at least not yet maybe he will be
they had him on the field 77 percent of
the time but he was mainly run blocking
but i think this is a game where tom
brady needs to settle in settle down and
just feast on that defense
score a lot of points get everybody to
forget about last week and then they
focus on moving forward and i still
think they can be really good if they
would lose this weekend though then it's
time to press the panic button
you know mike a couple days ago we were
talking about patrick mahomes and his
25th birthday we had a conversation
about mahomes and all the things he's
accomplished by the age of 25 and you
know the number i'm sure you've talked
about it many times on pft
but our conversation was our question
was
is he is he the best at 25
uh that we've seen and could he could he
be the best quarterback that we've ever
seen what do you think
i think if he stays healthy he'll end up
being the best quarterback of all time
now the measuring stick unfortunately is
going to be championships and i think
that's one of the reasons why even
though on the surface half billion
dollar contract sounds like a lot it was
structured in a way to help the chiefs
keep talent around him and that's what
they're chasing now that's the standard
getting to six and you've got some guys
on the team openly talking about getting
six or seven let's go one at a time
because they had to thread a pretty
tough needle last year in multiple
playoff games just to get their first
one but i think mahomes has a shot to be
regarded as the best ever and what
excites me about my homes and i said
this two years ago when we first saw all
the things he does
he's inspiring a generation of kids to
try to play quarterback the way he does
so in about 15 years there's going to be
a bunch of patrick mahomeses in the nfl
and the nfl is going to be better off
for it
all right what's popping on pft pm mike
well what we're going to do today is get
everybody ready for week two yeah we're
going to talk to tom curran of nbc
sports boston about what to expect on
sunday night go over all the injuries
we're going to do a feature since it's
our first friday everything is brand new
we're going to do what we're looking
forward to this weekend and shereen
williams and i are going to go back and
forth on that then we're going to answer
some questions to wrap up the day
because that's the easiest way to create
content just ask for questions answer
questions before you know the segments
we've both known him for a long time hey
thanks a lot mike
it to have you mike appreciate it let's
do it again anytime guys congratulations
on the show and you guys are doing a
great job
thanks man appreciate you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports